Is this the real life?
Is this just fantasy?
Caught in a landslide, no escape from reality.
Open your eyes.
Look up to the skies, and see...
I'm just a poor boy, I need no sympathy.
Because I'm easy come, easy go.
little high...
little low.
Anyway the wind blows.
It doesn't really matter to me.
...to me...
Mama, I just killed a man.
Put a gun against his head, pulled my trigger, now he's dead.
Mama...
Life had just begun, now I've gone and thrown it all away.
(mother cries)
I didn't mean to make you cry.
If I'm not back again, this time tomorrow...
Carry on.
Carry on, as if...
...nothing really matters.
It's too late.
My time has come.
Sends shivers down my spine...
Body's aching all the time.
Goodbye everybody, I gotta go.
Gotta leave you all behind.
Face the truth.
Mama.
(mother cries)
I don't wanna die.
I sometimes wish I'd never been born at all.
I see a little silhouetto of a man.
- Scaramouche, scaramouche.
Will you do the fandango?
Thunderbolt...
...and lightning.
Very very frightening.
Me.
Galileo.
- Galileo!
Galileo, figaro.
- Magnifico.
I'm just a poor boy.
Nobody loves me.
He's just a poor boy, from a poor family!
Spare him his life from this monstrosity.
Easy come, easy go.
Will you let me go?
- Bismillah!
No.
- We will not let you go.
Let him go, bismillah.
- We will not let you go!
Let me go.
- Will not let you go.
- Never.
Never let you go.
Let... me go.
- Never!
Ah, let me go!
- Ooh...
No. No, no, no!
No, no, no.
Oh mama mia, mama mia!
Mama mia, let me go.
- Beelzebub has a devil put aside for me.
For me.
Anyway the wind blows.
(Bloopers)
(Advertisement)